if you've been down in the dumps ever
since it was revealed in January 2019
that the sixth season of History's drama
series Vikings would be its last it's
time to pick yourself back up a new
Viking spin-off Series has been
announced Vikings Valhalla and it will
be streaming on Netflix the flagship
Viking series kicked off back in 2013
and quickly established itself as one of
the History Channel's most successful
shows while also blazing a new Trail for
the network as its first scripted
fiction project
to build is a historical drummer Vikings
has a largely invented narrative that
inserts real and legendary figures from
Norse culture into actual historical
events having them interact in ways that
historians deem unlikely in the early
Seasons a series followed Ragnar
Lothbrok a historically debatable figure
and folk hero of Scandinavia and his
wife lagatha a legendary ruler whose
historicity is also debated later
seasons of Vikings focus more on The
Offspring of Ragnar most notably bjn
Ironside and Ivar the Boneless
throughout this run Vikings has
chronicled well the Viking Way of Life
the Norse People's First forays into
England and France and the constant
power struggles and political
machinations that went on in Europe
during the 8th and 9th centuries so with
a lot of ground covered through six
seasons what's left to explore on
Vikings Valhalla he is everything we
know about the spin-off Series so far
spoilers for Vikings ahead before you
start scrolling through Netflix's
thousands of offerings looking for
Vikings Val know this the series is set
to premiere on Netflix on February 25th
2022 considering Vikings concluded on
December 30th 2020 audiences have had to
wait a while before the next iteration
of Vikings begin streaming into their
living rooms but they should find
comfort in knowing that Netflix has
already ponied up for a massive series
order in a rare turn of events Netflix
committed to a 24-episode package of
Valhalla eight of those episodes are
already reserved for the first season
and it's unclear how many episodes
subsequent seasons will be either way
the sheer size of the order speaks
volumes about the company's belief in
the series which is a smart play
considering the original series had a
sixth season run that spanned 89
episodes if there's one thing that
Vikings has been great at doing is
killing off its main characters season 3
saw the deaths of Earl haroldson's Widow
rollo's girlfriend Siggy and the priest
Ragnar's BFF athelston Viking season 4
knocked off Ragnar's second wife ausleg
his friend and rival King Egbert and
most shockingly of all Ragnar himself
who up until that point had been the
series main protagonist in season 5 as
more characters were added the bodies
continued to pile up it has been
confirmed that the new series will take
place around 100 years after the current
show so even the youngest Vikings
characters will be dead and gone by then
naturally Vikings Valhalla will feature
all new characters based on even more
historical figures from Norse Legend
further Hollywood Reporter some of the
main characters of Vikings Valhalla will
be Leif Ericsson Freitas Eric's daughter
Harold sigurdson Emma of Normandy and
King knuts the great Leif Erikson is
arguably the most famous of the larts he
has a pretty big claim to fame as he's
believed to be the first European to
discover North America rather than
Christopher Columbus not only that but
Leif Erikson is said to have done so a
whole half Millennium before Columbus
sailed the ocean blue setting foot in a
land he dubbed Finland back in the 11th
century then there's greatest life's
sister who's also said to have taken
part in the Finland Voyage though her
historical record is spotty she's always
portrayed as a fierce Warrior Vikings
Valhalla will almost certainly include
the sibling's trip to the New World In
His plot next is Harold hardrada born
about 45 years after Leif Erikson he's
regarded as the last great Viking leader
having fought for control of Norway and
Denmark before meeting his end during an
invasion of England his successor in
some respects was his contemporary the
Norman King William the Conqueror who
wasn't a viking but claimed Viking
ancestry as a descendant of the one and
only Rollo William conquered England
following Harold hardrada's defeat
becoming its king the pair's respective
battles were almost certainly factor
into the plot of Vikings Valhalla all
the same Netflix released the Show's
first trailer which is in a word
riveting naturally the trailer kicks off
with the Vikings at Sea during a rip
roaring storm and if the rest of the
footage is any indication there will be
a plethora of battle scenes which is
likely what fans of Vikings ordered up
in their dreams with Valhalla set to
premiere Friday February 25th on Netflix
audience members still have time to
watch the original series all the same
be prepared to travel the hair raising
seas and charge the bloody battlefields
with Viking Legends
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]